[Music]
you are such an accomplished actor stage
film you've done it all I did not
realize that you were a soap actor for
how long us about a year I did a year
yeah a year on a soap opera
yeah something I swore I'd never do and
then it came along and I was happened to
be starving at the time and it this is
really this will be good and actually
when one learns a lot because I wasn't
used to having cameras pointing at me
and and I wasn't used to doing that sort
of dialogue if you can call it that I
mean it was excuse me very difficult to
make those those words work and also
everyone I was working with had been on
for a long time and they were used to
just reading the teleprompter oh they
have teleprompters they did then maybe
nowadays people have implants or
something that tell them the line but
night you could always do it was so
funny because whenever there would be a
name they would always look away they'd
say well Jim I haven't first of all they
couldn't just say hi Jim how are you it
had to do you had to in case I'm gonna
admit the last couple of days every line
had to be packed with exposition for
anyone just tuning in so instead of hey
Conan nice to see you I haven't seen you
for a while it would be hi Conan I
because he they wouldn't memorize the
name so they'd see my name over there
yeah hi Conan I haven't seen you since
the plane crash and the Springfield
Memorial Hospital cafeteria
and and your wife left you and ran off
with Bernard
[Applause]
I love the storyline you just came up I
think that's fantastic
but no it is true I do think I always
know it's about soap operas is that
which always fascinating is that humans
in real life can read each other's
reactions if you say would you like to
go get some Italian food and I go ah you
go okay we won't do Italian putting in
soap operas no one ever reads the other
person's reaction you'll say maybe we
could get married and I go and then the
other person goes you're not happy about
that make up no no of course I am then
they go good let's get married they
don't read human reactions but also if
at the end and there's it's a convention
that I thank God movies and theater have
not taken up but the Stinger at the end
where they say and so I'll see you at
the bar mitzvah or whatever and then
rather than cut they'd leave it on you
your face well I go for a long time you
just have to go can I talk the person's
right here but I can't I had yourself to
it have to just yeah just look away
that slope yeah that's what it is it's
the slow push into your face no no
nobody come yeah yeah
no one in light what would be Paul's in
real life if you did that someone would
say are you having a stroke or you okay
yeah are you all right yeah or if
there's three people in the scene each
person gets their own slow push
we should do the talk show like that
from now on we should shoot it like that
we are like yes I'll see you we'll be
right back but then stay right here on
and then cut to between our different
faces yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
guys he just weed we've revolutionized
we can kill so much time as when one
gets the feeling interview you know
nothing under the REM you come on let's
try and do the whole Oh 40-minute
interview